[Musique]
je suis trop content mes parents m'ont
enfin acheté le téléphone que je voulais
je le kiffe trop et avec lui je peux
rester connecté avec mes
amis en vrai j'aimerais bien faire des
vidéos TikTok je serai connu et avec mes
vidéos je serai
riche encore sur ton
téléphone tu as fait au moins tes
devoirs
tu m'écoutes quand je te
[Musique]
parle mes parents me font chier ils sont
tout le temps sur mon dos pourquoi ils
me laissent pas vivre ma vie ils sont
égoïstes ils veulent que je sois leur
bon petit garçon c'est fini ça oh mon
garçon on va passer une bonne
journée
téléphone comment
[Musique]
nononeééone
téléphone
sortez de ma chambre
[Musique]
sortez
c'est trop drôle il un mec
quiene des vidéos tikt ah
oua si
ça Mo je pas pas je pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vas-y
un téléphone en pluséléphone en plus oh
nul nul e vas-y Tomas envoie-moi la
vidéo comme ça je vais poster sur TikTok
on va faire des millions de vues ça va
baiser ça va Baer tu vas voir tu vas
[Applaudissements]
voir ça bouge plus ou quoi arrête
les
nul
nul salut bbé tu as vu ma vi sur TikTok
elles font des millions de vues tu as vu
oui j'ai vu pierre mais mais je suis
choqué vous êtes empris à une personne
innocente elle avait rien demandé c'est
de la pure violence gratuite vous l'avez
attaqué gratuitement et en plus vous
rigolez j'ai hallucine ou quoi mais
c'est c'est quoi ce bordel Jessica
commence pas à me prendre la tête déjà
mes parents me font chier et toi tu t
maintenant non mais ça m'inquiète vous
êtes tous complices d'une agression tu
te rends compes ou pas allez c'est bon
j'agè tout suite les grand mot c juste
pour
rire plus douce allez bébé tu es
tellement belle en plus ones que tous
les deux sur messenger ah ouais
tu je sais pas pour voir non tu es pas
sérieux allez on est re nous
deux comme
ça vas-y continue tu es trop
bonne vas-y vas-y continue
continue wou G a fait plein de vu
celle-là salut salut les amis vous allez
bien salut qu'est-ce qui se passe
bizarre non il est là ouais moi ça va et
vous bah il se passe
quoi vous avez l'air bizarre et tout
alors marin ça va tu te prends pour qui
toi mais qu'est-ce tu tu Mais qu'est-ce
tu tu avais moins dire pour mais
casse-toi en fait mec casse-toi
casse-toi casse-toi c la maintenant ben
alors casse-toi j'ai pas envie de
t'entendre
allez ben les gars vous êtes sérieux ou
quoi la façon comment il parle ça vous
choque pas ou quoi non tu as pas vu la
vidéo mais quelle vidéo tiens regarde tu
as pas vu la vidéo non j'ai j'ai pas vu
fais voir
tiens c'est
chaud non mais les gars vous m'avez rien
dit là je viens comme une débile ici FZ
de
[Musique]
moi
allô pierre
oui qu'est-ce que tu as
fait qu'est-ce que tu as
fait tu as vu la vidéo oui j'ai vu la
vidéo je l'ai
vu que ça dire je suis trop content moi
tu es vraiment trop bonne en plus mais
comment ça tu es trop content tu m'avoue
tu l' h devant tout le monde jeé devant
nos amis j'étais trop contente de les
voir et j'apprends quoi on peut passer
pour une [__] tu as pensé à mes
parents tu m'as fout tu la
hte comment tu as pu faire ça à
moi toi pas t mais comment tu veux que
je me
calme jeis pas de souci de ce que pit
pas B mais tu m'as détruit mon image tu
sais que je suis quelqu'un qui est pas
comme ça demain je l'ai fait par amour
par amour pour toi et tu as détruit mon
image tu as même pas pensé à ce que je
pouvais endurer par la suitei
[Musique]
oui moi je te faisais confiance quand je
t' fait ça je pensais pas que tu allais
la
publier
bon éoute c'est pas parler
là ser
mais tu es
sérieux mais je m'en fous des vu ça que
tu comprends pas je m'en
fous c'est ça que tu comprends pas parce
que toi ton je l'ai pas détr oui mes
parents il vont dire
quoi j'auris plus une vie normale à
cause de
toi tu peux plus parler là allez vas-y
ciao
[Musique]
ciao marque pas
M peux rien dire M Paran
c'est trop la
[Musique]
honte je sais il me reste qu'e chose à
faire
[Musique]
ça fait longtemps que je
t'app bon j'en ai Mar
j'arrive
Jessica Jessica non non non tu réponds
pas c'est quoi ça
Jessica
[Musique]
Jessica pourquoi tu
papa c'est quoi est
t'aré pourquoi
[Musique]
moi
non non l'aurais
pu faire quoi
[Musique]
non mobilisons-nous agissons ensemble
utilisons internet et les réseaux
sociaux AB Bonn etciant soyons vigilants
pour l'avenir de nos enfants les réseaux
sociaux un danger
[Musique]
sous-estimé